uh good evening members it is uh seven
o'clock um and welcome to this planning
committee
of the 16th of march 2022.
um before we go into the business of
committee tonight um
i would ask you just to stand for a few
moments including members of the public
and our officers
uh just to
put our thoughts to what's going on in
the ukraine so if you wouldn't mind
thank you members
right once again
welcome as always uh just a little bit
of housekeeping
uh i must read to you um if the fire
alarm is activated please vacate the
offices via the stairs
either through the security door
to
i always say this but my right your left
which is the door
on my right
use the corridor and the stairs where
you came in please do not
use the lifts
officers will be available to assist you
and
it will
all be well we don't have fire alarms go
off but
the officers will bring you back
when it's safe to do so
and please form on the green in hawley
square
does anybody here this evening i wish to
film the proceeds of the meeting
no thank you very much
uh the restriction of the use of mobile
phones with everybody please make sure
that their mobile phones are turned to
silent
and they are not used to make or receive
phone calls in the chamber whilst this
meeting is in progress
uh notification
to the planning committee would members
please note that agenda item 6
which is number 60 northumberland avenue
will not be discussed at this meeting
as the application has been withdrawn
by the applicant from the planning
register
would any member who wishes to speak
who's not on the committee under council
procedure 20.1
uh please show the hand now
uh councillor trevor shonk
and what item council shank
thank you
thank you very much
uh public speaking the following
application has been reserved for public
speaking
with members please note that item
4 f
we have public speaking
thank you
moving on to
the agenda apologies for absence gender
item one
i have received apologies from
councillor coleman cook
councillor hart
councillor rozeski
who i believe john
john is over there i stand in thank you
john
uh standing in
also
councillor paul moore
are there any other apologies
thank you members
agenda item 2 are there any declarations
of interest
okay thank you
agenda item three minutes of the
planning committee held on the 19th of
january two months ago
um
two members agree that the minutes of
the planning committee held on that date
be approved by myself
could i have a proposal please cancel
auburn
seconded by councillor right do you all
agree
thank you members
i will now hand over
to
mr livingston who has a point of
information
thank you chairman i've got a point of
information on two of the items before
planning committee this evening
one on schedule item 4f which is
sterling way so in addition to the
reason why the application is being
reported to members as stated in the
report
the development also represents a minor
departure from policy e01 which is the
euro ken flexible uses policy for parts
of the site adjacent the access so the
area is going to be identified to
members in the presentation and the
policy will also be outlined for members
consideration this evening
on schedule item 4g
which is the land to the north of
fairlawn road and the west of north
northwood road broadstairs
uh the report has published does not
include the comment from broadstairs and
sir peter's town council
and i just wanted to apologize for the
omission of that comment
for members reference the comment reads
uh the planning committee of the town
council has considered this application
and has resolved unanimously to
recommend refusal the committee strongly
objects to this proposal due to the
layout and density of the buildings the
well-being of future residents in an
area of over-developed land the impact
on the parking and accessibility for the
road there is a lack of information
regarding the treatment and retention of
all trees and vegetation in the area of
development
additionally for that application one
plan of the street elevation for the
development has been updated as it
incorrectly showed the neighboring
properties adjacent to the to the scheme
and therefore condition two on the
application is updated with the correct
plan reference
which is pl 1.1
thank you chair
uh thank you ian
uh
gender item
four is scheduled planning applications
and public speaking
agenda
for
f
is the land on the north side of
stirling way ramsgate
speaking in favor of this application mr
hume mr hume
are you
oh replacement i thought you i thought
you would change you you may stay out
there using the microphone if you wish
okay thank you you have three minutes
thank you
good evening i represent kentish project
a fanatic-based housebuilder i aim from
the start of this journey when we
submitted the original application three
years ago in march 2019
was to deliver one two and three bedroom
housing for first-time buyers
we did not think that this would be
controversial because the site is
allocated for housing in the adopted
plan
and had previously been granted
permission for development as part of a
larger scheme
it is relevant that there is a 45 meter
distance of separation from the closest
part of the two developments from the
school
and the free story element is 60 meters
away from the school
the two-story height and in places
three-story height of the apartment is
we believe in keeping with the character
of the area and is well designed in our
view
this conclusion has been supported twice
by your head of planning
the october decision to grant permission
was later challenged on procedural
grounds not on the planning merits of
the decision
but because of the suggestion by the
school that the council decision was
biased because panic council along with
kent county council were perceived as a
financial beneficiary of this grant of
planning permission
it had actually taken 18 months from our
submission of application after a number
of round of design changes with the case
officer
we really do not believe that there
could be any suggestion of bias because
of financial gain from this decision
following the judgment in july 2021 we
have talked with the school and
additional information has been prepared
relating to the air quality
highway and noise as well as an updated
appropriate assessment
all statutory consultees have considered
the application in the light of the high
court judge's decision
and support the recommendation for
approval
in summary this site will deliver 38
smaller dwellings for first-time buyers
of which at least 11
will be affordable homes
another important point is that the
scheme will be sustainably constructed
with cutting-edge modular construction
and the residential accommodation will
be highly energy efficient
this scheme will deliver other benefits
including significant financial
contributions to other special education
schools at fallen's fields
25k to improve play equipment at nearby
jackie bakers and a medical and
community facility contribution focused
at westwood of circa 38k
for these reasons i would request on
behalf of kentish projects as a local
house builder
that three years after we originally
submitted our proposal and 18 months
after we originally secured approval for
the first time
that the members support the
recommendation so that we can start
construction
thank you
thank you very much so i think you look
a little bit better than mr hume
speaking against this application is mr
milton milton
the head teacher of layland gap school
yes um if i'm if i can hold you there a
moment mr milton
i will
nothing to hide from you i can assure
you normally we have members would know
this um
something from the antiques roadshow
which would time
our speakers with colored lights on the
top of it sitting over here
and now clark would push the button for
the three minutes
we don't have that tonight we have
modern technology
of a phone
um
but it will not
buzz or make any
sound
when your three minutes is up so i'm
keeping
oh it will chime at three minutes so
that that's more exciting i wasn't aware
of that thank you estelle
good evening let me know when the three
minutes start
i think we can start thank you mr milton
thank you for waiting there thank you
referencing pages 90 to 104 of your
supporting documents mr timothy corner
qc in the high co court of justice
stated that the application on behalf of
the council and under the scheme of
delegation had to be determined by the
planning committee he stated the council
had a clear financial interest in
planning permission being obtained for
development of the site as part of the
portfolio of land interests conveyed to
eko by the council and county council it
follows that in my judgment this
application should have been determined
by the planning committee
so it was made clear that the previous
decision by an officer was unlawful the
same judgment stated i think a
fair-minded observer would conclude
there was real possibility of bias yet
today as a committee you're proposing to
defer and delegate the approval to a
planning officer to me the apparent bias
has never been more evident than now
i ask that as a committee you defer only
and that you make this decision please
do so carefully as i feel that you're at
risk of repeating a decision process
which the high court of justice has
already judged to be unlawful
this was a great expense to this council
the master plan included a density plan
for this proposed residential
development it identifies this area of
land for 20 dwellings this planning
application is for 38 this 90 increase
in dwellings means that this application
results in building houses within a few
meters of pupils learning spaces play
areas and recreational space
this 90
increase will result in 90 more air
pollution 9 more noise pollution ninety
percent more demand on the road outside
lanham gap school than was originally
agreed
leyland gap school is a special needs
school for pupils with communication and
interaction difficulties ninety-one
percent of our pupils out of diagnosis
of autism many of our children are
extremely sound sensitive the dev
developers did meet with myself
a summary of which is we know it's going
to be dusty and noisy we'll do the
noises things in holidays and we'll put
up a fence
i do not consider this to be effective
mitigation
for the inevitable construction
disruption to our pupils and their
well-being and their learning this
planning application has been littered
with mistakes from the beginning the
environment agency submitted listed as
natural england actually refers to 145
dwellings at canterbury road so in
reference to pages 170 107 to 113 of
your documentation the council have not
met the requirements of regulation 63 of
habitats and species regulation 2017.
the habitat regulations have clear
appropriate assessment requirements
they have
there has clearly been insufficient
assessment which i understand is a
failure to apply local plan policy sp14
in the 131 available documents i cannot
see so i've got 10
to 15 more seconds as it wasn't for
please
just allow me to scenario thank you in
the 131 available document i cannot see
any reference to our school drainage
system and the fact that our attenuation
tanks are partly situated in this
development area furthermore when so
many objections are from families with
disabled children i find it
incomprehensible that there is no
reference to the equalities act no
equality impact assessment to me this is
a gross failure in your public sector
equalities duties
when kent county council shared the
contribution calculators earlier it was
based on 29 dwellings not 38. this is
clearly a saving to the developers and
it clearly shows apparent bias to me
this highly dense development and the
loss of community space will have a
significant detrimental impact on
leyland gap school and our community
before making your decision please
scroll through the pages of objections
listed on the planning portal
thank you for having an open meeting
thank you for your listening and
patience and recording my objections and
concerns and i do want it noted that i
dispute the 45 meters from the school
that i believe that to be incorrect
uh thank you mr middleton thank you
i do believe we have a mrs joe holden
who wishes to speak
mrs holden if you're there please
again you have
three minutes
i shall wait to sit down before we get
big ben working
thank you okay
ready yeah good evening my name is joe
holden and i'm parent to lacey may who
attend salem gap it's my intention this
evening to give you a point of view from
a special needs parent
the children that attend leyland gap all
have autism alongside other diagnoses
these children see the world in a
heightened state imagine all of your
senses working in overdrive
everything's a little louder smells are
stronger and change is really
frightening
our children like familiarity a
structured day
and where possible a quiet calm
environment
they do their best to control the
environment around them as this makes
them feel safe
when changes happen they can't control
this often results in a meltdown
this is where the behaviour
the child can't control their behavior
and it almost like reboots their system
now imagine building works taking place
next to your safe space the change of
routine the noise the smell the dust all
invading our children's senses i have
real concerns over our children's mental
health and well-being
leyland is a safe haven for our children
where the staff work extremely hard to
provide and maintain a suitable
environment
with the new planning development the
road entering the school is going to be
even busier
this raises concerns with emergency
services being able to reach the school
in a safe time frame
with the road being busier this brings
more obstacles to our children
my daughter for example is frightened of
motorbikes so if there's a busy road
going through she would be frightened
and would stand with her hands over her
ears i know other children would bolt
there's insufficient parking outside the
school as it goes so the parents park
along a single place
this already becomes congested
thankfully the traffic using this road
at the moment is that of the special
needs
that is that parents of the special
needs children so they're more aware
the school was originally promised a 20
square meter area between the car park
as a nature garden this in error was
missed off the deeds
the now proposed entrance is going to be
to a high density overcrowded
development invading our children's
privacy overlooking the sixth form block
and the children's play area the need
for sen schools is in high demand would
this land not be of better use to
provide more spaces for those children
needing specialist education there are
many children in phanet out of school
due to the lack of a suitable provision
do the right thing
these are special needs children whose
everyday life is already a challenge
don't be responsible for adding more
pressure to that of the children's lives
and of their families
thank you for listening
thank you very much uh and i'll call
upon the board counsellor
councillor shank
uh speaking under 20.1
and please councillor shank can you keep
good evening on the county council can
you keep to the subject yeah i'm just
letting you know who i am and where i'm
at
i'm a county county councillor so i do
have a lot of demons with these schools
anyway i had a phone call this morning
and the chat was quite knowledgeable
knowledgeable about the whole effect
here then i actually asked him to turn
up here tonight he said he preferred me
to stand and talk stern in way
now we're not against housing it's the
quantity
lanham cat school is a special needs
school
and i'm talking for the children
which we all seem to forget
so we're not against the housing it's
the quantity
i've had lots of knowledge for these
children one to one and two to one
it's just
we're here to represent all the people
that vote for us
traffic congestion
sterling way i've been up around there
today it's a complete nightmare
you can't get in you can't get out
air pollution
i don't know why i'm part of cases you
know i don't know why we get one saying
let's have more roads and roads it's
more traffic
when these children try to play outside
you're gonna and the houses are right
next door you're gonna have music
lawn mowers do it yourself
and they'll probably start complaining
about the noise of the children but it
does happen
so here i am
which is not something i normally do
trying to speak up for the school
all the mothers that take their children
to these schools and it's hard work it's
it must be a bit of a respite to take
them children to school
but if you go to london gap the pounds
help out on there
so it's quite a
privilege to stand here and actually
speak up for the children because it's
there the future
and if you see the mini buses and the
distance they travel to these schools
all i'm saying is
we're not going to housing it's the
quantity of housing right next to that
school
i think i'm going to leave it there
but let's just
say
this little thing about the children
thank you
thank you councillor shank now called
upon the plane officer which i believe
is emma
to outline the report thank you members
thank you chairman the application site
is outlined in red on this slide
um
to the bottom of the slide is sterling
way
um this road to the north west of the
slide is ozangel place
um in terms of the surrounding era this
is leyland gap school to the top of the
slide
you can see the
milo innovation center
here
and then over on the right hand side
here is royal harbour academy
and to the left of the site is um the
business units within the employment
area on euro camp
so this is an aerial view of the site so
the application site is in this location
here
so you can see the site is within close
proximity of westwood town centre so
westwood town centre is is to the top of
this slide
um again you can see that this area
in this location here is the employment
area a serving and business units on the
euro kent site
and again here you can see leyland gap
school
so this area um
all around here on the left hand side
here and on the right here you'll see
later in another slide the the full
outline but this area is all allocated
for housing in the thanet local plan
to the south here you can see this is um
sterling bay and you can see the
existing residential properties on the
estate
so this is a closing view of the site so
again the application site is this area
here to the bottom of the slide
again you can see later gap school in
this location here the innovation center
and royal harbour academy here and again
the employment site on the left
and then this is just another view of it
so you can see again the the design this
is now a more of a 3d view so you can
see the height of the units and scale of
the units and
the designs of the units and on the
left-hand side here again you can see
the existing semi-attached properties in
sterling way
and then again a more detailed view so
you can see from this view that there's
a also a pedestrian link that currently
connects from um osangel place to
sterling way you can see the the line
through here and there's some existing
trees along the edge of sterling way
these are four outside the application
sites the application site is actually
set back from sterling way following
this line here and there's a small
buffer between the application boundary
and the path in sterling way
so these are now photos of the site so
this is taken from sterling way looking
towards the application site
so the application site um is from this
point here and and back so it's this
area of overgrown land
on the left hand side is the leyland gap
school so you can see it's a three-story
flat roof building then you can see in
the center of the slide
the
marlow innovation center
and on the right hand side you can see
the royal harbor academy
and then this is looking off to the east
so sterling way is on the right hand
side and this is the existing footpath
cycle link you can see some existing
trees these to be retained these fall
outside the application site because
again the boundary runs along this area
here
and then this is again showing um
sterling way and showing the footpath
connection that people are currently
using to access sterling way
and then this is now looking further to
the west so again you can see um lane
and gap school in this location here and
you can see looking at these photos the
the design and materials have been used
so they're quite colorful buildings
you've got um blue and white cladding
used in this location and then um the
innovation centres orange
and again a royal um
harbour academy is again a
a colorful cladding has been used on
these they're quite modern design
buildings
and then this is looking to the far west
at the existing
um employment units within euro kent so
they're two-story
um with a um
a curved roof and again a metal clad
so this is now walking towards osangel
way so this is the
currently a pedestrian link that is used
and then as i get closer here this area
of land is is currently fenced off but
this is the location of the proposed
access into the site so the access would
be from osinger place and not from
sterling way
and then this is the current pedestrian
link
between the parking area linked to the
business units
and again with the application site on
the right hand side here
and now this is in osangeld place
looking back towards the application
site so again the application site is
from
this boundary here
to this boundary here so in between the
fencing
so the access proposed into the site
would be in this location here served
off off this road
and you can see the um existing
footpath and cycle link and this would
extend through into the site and extend
back through onto a sterling way
then this is looking from that point now
towards haine road so hane road is in
the distance you have leyland gap on the
right hand side
and the access here is the access into
the business units
and then this is looking back at the
business units just so you can see a
close-up design of the units and the use
of cladding and the the modern materials
and appearance
and then this is now looking at the
access into layland gap school so you
can see there's a wide access with um
drop curve for pedestrian crossing
across that access
and then this is now looking towards the
junction onto hane road
and you can see that there's um a small
island in the center here and there's a
drop kerbs that extend on either side of
the road
so this is the um
policy for the site so it's sp09 which
is a policy for the development of the
site for housing and
commercial use so the area within the
dotted red line
forms part of the policy allocation
the application site is this area to the
bottom of the slide within this within
this area here
um so the site is addicted as a whole
for 550 units
we currently have a pending application
in for 500 units
within this area here
and this area here so that's currently
um pending and this proposed application
is for 38 units so
the combined
number currently falls below the 550
that the site as a whole has been
allocated for
then just just so you wear this area
here is allocated um for commercial and
that has had an application approved for
commercial development outline
form um with an element of that being
full
and at the moment we have not received
any applications for this area here but
again this area in the original master
plan was um shown as being employment
land
so in terms of um
what was mentioned at the beginning of
of the discussion tonight part of the
site does fall outside the allocation so
this dotted line here
shows the area that's allocated for
housing
and this
area here is actually outside of the
housing adaptation and is therefore
covered by
the um employment land policy for the
overall euro kent site
so it would be a departure on the basis
that it is using land that is allocated
for employment but given the fact that
this is an allocated housing site and
this is the
um form of access that would be to the
site and also given the fact that the
site is actually quite small and could
actually not accommodate
um a commercial development it's not
considered that there would be
harm to that policy so whilst it is a
departure it's an acceptable departure
on the basis that housing will be
achieved and great weight is given to
the fact that it is a housing allocation
site
so this is the proposed layout plan and
so as much as for 38 units
so um there's these terrorist units here
are blocks of houses so again blocks of
houses here these are two bed at the
bottom
the rest of the house is a three bed and
then on the top right hand corner this
is a block of flats so this is a
three-story building in the car
in the corner that accommodates one and
two bed units all of the houses are
two-story
um and you can see that there's a
parking courts off to the west here and
up here to the west
and then other
the other units have parking to the
front of the properties
so in terms of the impact on the current
of the area some concerns that have come
through with the objections is to do
with the general loss of open space and
the fact this area is used as recreation
space
um the site is advocated for housing and
therefore given the fact that we would
give
a significant weight to the fact it has
a housing allocation
and given the fact that the site is
located in quite close proximity to
jackie baker's recreation ground
um it's not considered there'll be
a significant harm to the area through
the loss of this space for for
recreational
informal recreational use so it's not
allocated for recreation it's just
that's how it how it has been used
in terms of the number it it's been
mentioned a few times about the number
of units and the fact that um it was
understood that there would be fewer
units on this site that formed part of
a previous plan on the original outline
application that was a 2011 application
and that's no longer
um
that's no longer an extent scheme so
there's no reference to be made to that
previous application other than the fact
that
we have previously approved the
principle of residential development on
this site there was no detailed plans at
that point it was just an outline
application
and the suggestion that there was 20
units on this site was part of a
parameter plan that was an indication of
what could be achieved on this site
but the
matter for members tonight is to
consider whether this number of units
actually results in harm to the current
appearance of the area or whether
there's any other
material
considerations that would result in harm
such as haunted the school or
neighbouring impact or highways so
that's the the matter for members
tonight rather than a consideration of
the fact that this exceeds a number that
was shown on a historic plan
so this is the layout in more detail so
what's been proposed is blocks of
terraces and the reason for this is that
um regard has been given to
the
layout and design of the neighbouring
business units which are long
two-story units
so whilst this site can be seen from
sterling way it's actually not seen in
the context of sterling way because
there's
um a green buffer that separates the
site from sterling weight itself and the
properties all back on to sterling waste
and they're not fronting sterling way
and therefore aren't necessarily seen
in the context of sterling way they're
more seen as seen from ozinger place and
therefore in the context of
the buildings i've showed you which are
the leyland gap school the business
units
and the innovation centre
so for this reason the the units have
been designed in quite a modern way with
quite
modern um and
sort of colorful materials to respect
the character of those
those buildings and in a similar way
that this is how this is the passenger
development has has appeared in that
this is respecting the
layout of the neighboring
business units
and then in terms of the flat
development the appearance and scale of
this is very similar to the building on
the leyland scaps school so just to show
you the elevation so this is the flat
development
so you can see it's a three-story flat
roof building
with modern cladding
so blues and grays and stone colors have
been used there's some balconies on it
and the elevations are quite staggered
so it's quite um
there's quite a lot of relief in the
elevation so it's not just one big block
it's quite staggered in the elevations
and the balconies give sort of um
sort of projections coming out of the
building
so in terms of it
the scale of this or what is um
a large building again in the context of
the other large buildings nearby is not
considered to be out of keeping with um
with those buildings
so this is just the floor plan showing
the units
so it contains
um 15 one bed and two bed flats so nine
of them are one bed and six are two bed
and then this is the three bed house
design
so you can see it's quite an industrial
appearance so again in in character with
the business units and the design and
it's been given to those units so
it's um timber card with a metal
cladding as well no sorry not typically
it's brick with a metal clad in
um
and you can see a interesting roof
design that's being used so whilst it's
a terrorist
block the actual height of the building
is quite low because it's a very shallow
roof
and you and it'll be quite an
interesting um
stagger in the height of the roof as it
goes along the terrace
so and then this is the two bed units so
again similar in design to the three bed
but slightly smaller
these are elevations so you can see
how it would look in the street
so the top elevation is the view from
inside the site
um
and showing that it's showing the ground
level difference so
on the right hand side
of the slide this is um
showing the
height of buildings within sterling way
so this is an example of one of the
semi-detached units that would be in
sterling way
this here is sterling weight itself then
you can see
the setbacks of the green verge that
would be between the development site
and sterling ray and then you can see
the ground level drop
so this drops at 0.8 meters
and then you can see there will be three
dwellings in this corner and then you
can see the flat development
and then this bottom um elevation is
taken from inside the site so it's
looking towards the northern boundary
so inside the site you'd be looking at
the flat block on the right hand side
then you can see there's um
a spacious gap before reaching the the
block of five
terrace units and then due to the
orientation of the units on the
left-hand side you'll just to see the
side elevation of that unit
and then so that was taken from inside
looking towards the northern side
and then these um this elevation is
taken from again inside the site but now
looking to the south so i just flipped
back to that so this is taken from
the center of this road looking towards
these units on the south so these are
the two bed units
and you can see again the terrace rows
you can see the interesting roof form of
those units and then on the left hand
side you can see the three units that
were in the
southeast corner of the site
and then this central um slide is
basically taken from osinger place
looking into the development
so you'd see the five units that would
then face towards the access and you can
see the block of flats behind it and the
side elevation of the two um story two
bed terrace units on the right hand side
and again you can see the ground level
change in relation to sterling way
and then the bottom slide is taken from
um
from sterling way so this would be the
view looking from sterling way towards
the site so you could again because the
ground level difference you can see
there's um it's slightly reduced in this
location here and then you'll see the
side view of the three houses and again
the flat block to the rear
so in terms of landscaping within the
site
hedging is proposed around the entire
boundary of the development
and there's a suggestion that up to 25
trees would be planted within the site
so there's um
areas here that are showing the
potential tree planting and showing up
to 25 trees could be accommodated within
the site and that would then form part
of a future landscaping plan that has
been conditioned
you can see that there would be the
grass
verge was it would is this location here
and you can see the footpath connection
that would extend from the access way
down to sterling ray in this location
here
and then in this far
south west corner this area here is
designated for grassland
so as part of the ecology assessment of
the site it was found that whilst
reptiles aren't actually
present within the site there is some
botanical interest within the site so
this area has been designated as
grassland
and some
botanical interesting plants have been
found somewhere else on the site are
being relocated to this corner and this
area is being safeguarded for that
um in terms of the the um hard surfacing
the parking area is all um due to be
paved and so there would be it's not
just a a massive tarmac there is paving
in there amongst the the tarmac for the
road
and you can see in terms of general
landscaping that every property has a
real garden area and there's some um
areas of soft landscaping around the
parking space that could be planted to
create some softening of the development
so in terms of the impact on living
conditions for the properties in
sterling way
there's not considered to be a
significant impact on these properties
there's a 43 meter distance between the
proposed development and the properties
in sterling way and there's the 0.8
meter ground level difference so it is
actually lower
so
it's not considered there any issues
with light or outlook and in terms of
overlooking that distance is considered
to be adequate to prevent any
significant loss of privacy and they
would be backing onto the front of
properties as well so no loss of rear
immunity privacy
in terms of the impact of the score this
has been mentioned through a number of
letters of of objection
so concerns have been to do with the
impact on
the privacy of the students and
overlooking of the
central um play area
and also of the accommodation block in
this location here
so in terms of the distances there's um
45 meter distance from
and this was slightly incorrect in the
report so it's a 45 meter distance from
this point here this corner
to the
play space
within the center of the site
and there's a 30 meter distance from
the corner of here so unit 6 towards the
accommodation block
so the the original application that
came in i'll just show you
the layout so this was the original
layer on the site
and it did involve
the thought the rear elevation of all of
the dwellings looking in the direction
of the school so there was
concern raised with that layout
so this has been amended to
reorientate this block
so that the closest units to the school
um no longer have habitable room windows
looking towards a school
whilst there's a single first floor side
window within this block here
this is obscure glazed and high level so
this would not overlook the school so
the nearest windows to over the school
would be within the rear elevation of
the central unit so plots six to ten
and as mentioned due to the distance and
the fact that whilst
this area here which is the play space
this is the i believe to be the main
area of concern for for parents in terms
of overlooking
the as i said the distance at this point
is the 45 meters from this unit here to
that space
for these units here the existing
building would be blocking some of this
space
it's considered that this distance is
adequate to significantly um or to
prevent any significant loss of privacy
for those those students
i've
i'll just show you this this is just a
plan this is not an actual submitted
plan this is just a plan i've tried to
create just to show you a visual so you
can understand the relationship of the
um play space and the buildings so it's
not completely accurate but i'm just
trying to give you an indication of
where the open space was because it's
different difficult to tell on
the black and white plans so this is the
field area here and this is
approximately the distance from the
houses and you can see the main
orientation of these windows is actually
looking over the parking area
of
the marlow um
uh
innovation center
and it's not actually directly
overlooking the school
site although there would be some
oblique views from these windows towards
that that open space
and then in terms of the flat block um i
think again concerns were raised to do
the fact there were some balconies on
the front elevation of these flat blocks
and the impact of this on
the um play area this is 60 meters from
the balconies here to the actual
boundary of the school
so again this is considered to be
an adequate distance well there would be
some long maybe some long-distance views
it's not because it just be harmful
enough to
to warrant the refusal on that
particular issue
um in terms of noise concern was has
been raised um as you've heard on the
on on
concern on the um
the impact on the children within the
school from the construction noise from
the development
so um originally this was felt it could
be dealt with through a condition
through a construction management plan
condition
but through the judicial review it was
considered that we should look at this
in this issue in more detail
so
a construction noise assessment has been
submitted with this application which
considers the impact from the proposed
development during construction on the
school
the construction noise assessment has
concluded that the impact would be
acceptable but subject to mitigation
measures
so this included
building an enclosure around the piling
rig which is likely to have the greatest
noise impact
providing a perimeter screen of 2.4
meters high around the entire building
site
and also limiting construction hours to
between 7am and 6pm monday to friday and
8am to 1pm on saturdays
so these these hours of construction
have been conditioned and there's also a
condition
that requires the submission of the
construction management plan that takes
into account the mitigation measures
that have been
listed within the construction noise
assessment so this will again be fully
looked at but um
we all we we have the mitigation
measures that are needed in order to
reduce the impact on um the students in
the school of it's difficult to to fully
um deal with that issue given the fact
that the site is allocated for housing
and we would expect construction to come
forward on this site
so it's very difficult to completely
deal with with any noise issues from
construction but through this report
it's looked to minimize those to reduce
the impact on the children as much as
possible
so in terms of the highway impact
so access to the site is going to be
from osingle and place in this location
here so the access is going to be in
this far corner into the site and you
can see the proximity to
the school access
um
in terms of the
talk about the layout first in terms of
the layout um adequate
maneuvering and turning plans have been
submitted tracking plans for
large can large vehicles have been
submitted so that adequate turning
within the site
there's 64 parking spaces and this is
considered by highways to be the
minimum number of parking spaces
required to to serve the development so
that has been achieved within the site
um
as mentioned earlier the footpath
connection has been achieved so there
will be um
pedestrian movement through the site and
cycle um
cycle movement as well through the use
of the path for
psycho for bikes as well
um
and then
a raised table has been proposed in this
section here because the fact that
there's a bit of a bend in the access in
order to reduce vehicle speeds the
raised table was proposed in this
location so it will reduce the speed of
vehicles as it leaves the site
now concern was raised again during the
judicial review that consideration
hadn't been given to the independent
journeys of of um students and peoples
to the school
so
pupils are encouraged to to walk to the
school and there's been concern that
increased vehicle movements along
osangel place could result in
safety concerns for the students
so kcci rays have been further consulted
through this application
and
an
addendum has been submitted by the agent
the addendum has stated that the in
terms of the impact for pedestrians the
paths around the site are 2.5 meters
wide so the the wider the quite wide
path says the tracking has shown this
sufficient space
on all of the roads to enable turning
without any overhanging of the footpaths
and
as mentioned there was the the raised
table would reduce speeds for from of
vehicles leaving the site and would
allow an actual crossing point
potentially
across the access point within the site
as well
so kcc highways have come back and and
have raised no concerns with this
there's a as you can see on this
aerial view here there's crossing points
to the central island point here so any
children that will walk into the site
from the south
they can
cross this road here across this road
here and then walk around and then
there's a crossing point the access to
the school as well
and if coming from the north there's a
footpath a continuation of footpath all
the way around and then if anybody was
coming from the sterling way direction
there's now the pedestrian link a formal
pedestrian that's being created and then
the raised table that will allow for a
safe crossing area
in terms of vehicle movements it it's
been determined that there would be
approximately one vehicle movement per
three minutes
and that this is not um a significant
number of vehicle movements that could
result in any highway safety impact
um in terms of the actual off-site
contribution so with the original
application there were some
contributions from um the developments
what off-site highway works but given
the size of this development of only 38
units it's not considered justified
to request
a contribution because it's not
considered there'll be significant harm
from the size of the development
this has also been the reason as to why
a transport assessment has not been
required because 38 units is quite a
small number and is not considered to
result in
significant harm on the highway
in terms of air quality
um again through the judicial review
concern was raised with the fact that an
adequate air quality assessment has not
been submitted
um through this application we've
reconsulted with environmental health
and environmental health have confirmed
confirmed that an air quality assessment
is not required
an air quality assessment is required
either where the scale of the
development warrants it or where it's a
highly trafficked pollution hotspot or
there's evidence of high pollution
now whilst thanit is currently within an
air quality management area and are
looking to revoke this as we've had
several years of the air quality
objectives not being exceeded
and in this particular location there
has been
um an area where there's been monitoring
carried out and it's shown that um last
lot from last year to now that is
actually
half the national
objective so it's actually a really
quite good air quality area it's not
causing any harm and therefore there's
not a need for an air quality assessment
and given the size of the development
again of the 38 units it's not
considered that would be enough to
require an air quality assessment in
this location
so in terms of um other issues
uh there's 30
affordable housing that's been provided
on the site
financial contributions towards um
kcc education and
health provision have all been
provided this actually has been updated
through
this application so where we've gone
back out to consultation kcc have come
back to us and requested additional
offsite contributions
so the so an additional fifty thousand
pound compared to what we were looking
at originally has now been um secured
through this application that will go to
additional um
social care and youth facilities within
the area
and so this is to be secured through
a revised legal agreement so whilst we
already have a signed legal agreement
for this site because of the increase in
the contributions we are going to need a
revised financial revised legal
agreement securing those contributions
and we haven't yet received that so that
is the reason for the application to be
deferred and dedicated it's just for us
to receive the legal agreement so
obviously members are making the
decision tonight
on whether the application is acceptable
and we would be looking solely for it to
be deferred and delegated just for us to
receive that legal agreement to secure
those contributions
and in terms of the appropriate
assessment so again this was looked at
through the jr and it was um
that our appropriate assessment needed
to be updated this has happened
we have consulted natural england
um a copy of the appropriate assessment
is contained with the in the um annex to
this um this report
and naturally i'm going to have raised
no concerns with its subject to us to
securing the contribution to
the special protection area which again
will form part of the legal agreement
that we're we're waiting to to be
submitted
so overall it's a it's a advocated
housing site well so a small part of it
is within the employment site we don't
consider that that will um is is harmful
and that it will actually help to serve
the housing development
um it's previously been approved as a
housing development
site
although the number have not been
approved and in terms of the actual
number and scale and design of the units
we do consider that this scheme is
appropriate in terms of the surrounding
carrots and appearance of the area
and in terms of the impact on
surrounding properties and the school
we do feel that full consideration has
been given to these impacts and
mitigation has been
dealt with where necessary and this is
all
dealt with through the safeguarding
conditions within the report and through
the legal agreement that we are waiting
for to secure the contributions
so it is recommended for deferring
delegates subject to that legal
agreement being submitted thank you
chairman
uh thank you for your detailed report
i'll just bring in mr livingston to
add a comment please
thank you chair um just wanted to
outline to members about the particular
point raised with regards to the public
sector equality duty that's been
mentioned
and so i just thought it'd be relevant
to just read that duty out to members so
you are aware of it as a particular
point so this is section
149 of the equality act 2010
and it's that a public authority must in
the exercise of its functions have due
regards the need to eliminate
discrimination harassment victimization
and any other conduct that is prohibited
by under the act advance equality of
opportunity between persons who share a
relevant protected characteristic and
persons who do not share it foster good
relations between persons who share a
relevant protected characteristic and a
person who does not share it
in addition
having regards the need to advance
equality of opportunity between persons
who share a relevant protected
characteristic and persons who do not
share it involves having due regard in
particular the need to
remove or minimize disadvantages
suffered by persons who share a relevant
protected characteristic that are
connected to that characteristic take
steps to meet the needs of persons who
share a relevant protected
characteristic that are different from
the needs of persons that do not share
it and encourage persons who share a
relevant protected characteristic to
participate in public life or in any
other activity in which participation by
such persons
is disproportionately low
now
disability is a protected characteristic
in particular the public sector equality
duty does state that the steps involved
in meeting the needs of disabled persons
that are different from needs of persons
who are not disabled include in
particular steps to take account of the
disabled person's
disabilities now in particular
this is something that has been looked
at in quite a lot of detail in the
office's recommendation
it's considered in the report when
looking at the issues of noise of
highways of layout as we've seen from
the changes that have been made as well
as the relationship with the school
so by virtue of that work and what's
outlined in the report the duty
has been an integral part of the
formation of the recommendation that's
been put to members this evening and
therefore in our view the duty has been
complied with even though there is no
explicit reference in the report to it
thank you chairman
uh thank you very much ian
i do note that mr milton has been
standing for quite some time mr milton
i'm afraid
if you wanted to speak i'm not allowed
to let you speak that are
that is part of the rules it's not me
being
awkward
but i'm afraid i can't let you speak
again you've made your comments
uh no
no i can't i'm
mr milton i'm sorry i can't allow that
it's um i'm just moving on with the
committee now for them to decide
thank you
uh thank you thank you very much i'm now
going
to
recommend
the office recommendation be adopted
could i have a second please
counselor bayford
thank you
right
i know we'll come to members cancer over
it first please
thank you chair yeah i i was sort of
waving vigorously at you because i
wanted to speak first um on the basis
partly that i am the other newington war
councillor a bigger pardon that's right
and
and um and i have been contacted by a
number of residents in stirling why who
are very concerned about this
application
um but apart from that i am a member of
the committee and obviously obviously
i'm looking at this
very hard and i have to say that it
troubles me
i think the history of the application
is unfortunate
um to say the least nevertheless i would
defend the council from any accusation
of bias the fact is the council is its
own planning authority and if the
council had owned the land outright and
was selling it to a developer it would
still have been considered in the
planning application so
it's a bit of an it's a bit of a
non-issue it's here before the committee
i think part of the problem here is that
the actual application site is in
northwood
and the um residents affected by it
which council junk and i both represent
are in newington
um
i note that the consultees in in the um
available on the on the system are the
northwood councillors or i'm sure have
uh important opinions about it but they
don't represent the residents who are
affected by it um council shank and i do
and i'm not just i'm not in any way um
dismissing their contributions i'm just
making the point that we are perhaps
more relevant in this case even though
the application site is in northwood
um
reviewing the history of the site i
think it's quite interesting that the
residential the principle of residential
development was established by the 2014
appeal decision and and i remember as i
suspect mr livingston does the original
2013 application being thrown out
members of the planning committee at the
time were not in favour of residential
development of this area and the
government inspector overruled them
that's how we got to where we are now
since then has been an adopted local
plan which has been incorporated but
since then also a school has been built
and i hear a
very eloquent case that's been put by
the head teacher and by the other
objector representing the pupil and we
do have to be mindful very mindful of
the impact of the children in the school
and i know that officers have done their
best to follow the advice that's been
given by the judge and mitigate those
effects but i personally am not
persuaded
i also know could because officers have
referred to it that there is another
planning application for 500 homes
pretty close to the school
likely to come forward we're not here to
consider that tonight we can only talk
about the application which is in front
of us but it does seem to me that this
is a skirmish in a larger war if that's
not an unfortunate analogy in the
present circumstances because the amount
of building that's going to go on in
that area is going to affect the school
however the school when it went there
and when this council gave whatever
permission he gave for the school or
whoever gave permission for the school
will have known that the whole site was
liable to be developed so
there are two sides to that coin
but i do it does concern me that we're
in a position
where the head teacher is coming here
clearly hasn't been involved in
discussions with the developer there
isn't any meeting of mines between the
parties
and i don't think that that's really
very happy i don't think the fact that
it's taken three years to get here is of
any relevance to the decision that this
committee needs to make
and i would ask members tonight to
consider very carefully what they are
giving consent to notwithstanding the
efforts have been made by officers and
the the excellent president lengthy very
lengthy presentation we've been given
about the detail of it i personally am
not happy to vote to approve for this
tonight and i'd ask other members to
give careful thoughts to their position
uh thank you councillor everett
councillor alban i believe you rachel
yeah thank you chair um
i think for for us all um it's a bit of
a battle between the head and the heart
and um and i think as councillor everett
said we need to think very carefully
about this
um
you know i i really do
sympathize with uh
the head teacher and oh is he gone oh no
he's there
and and and also
uh
the lady in relation to to the children
at the school um i think there's one
question just to get out of the way
one question chair is um
does thanic district council
get either get any financial or any
other business
for should this be approved that's the
one question whether that can be
answered whether uh our legal officer
can answer that i don't know
um
i think there's been other other issues
that have
been um raised
um
i'm mindful as well listening to the
head teacher in relation to
uh the point he said about the deferring
delegate
i think should we
i i actually accept that
and and i think that should uh this be
approved we should defer and it comes
back to uh
this
committee
um another question that i'd like to ask
chair
is um in relation to should this get
should we be mindful to approve this
um in relation to the construction
of the site
has any provision been made
for
uh within the application or within
conditions in relation to
uh vehicles of sight workers and the
reason i'm saying this chair is because
i know as well as a lot of us do that
whenever there's any site development
big or big or small
then the site workers park wherever they
like and they park up on the pavement
etc and that i'm i'm particularly
worried about
the the students having to come into the
school if they're blocking the access
footage for the students to come into
the school so i would need to know
whether any provision has been has been
placed there and uh thank you chair and
i look forward to listening to other
members thank you uh thank you council
auburn before bringing encounter bayford
uh i'm going to bring in our legal
officer as you've mentioned council
robin who may well be able to answer one
of your questions
thank you
thanks very much chair councillor
answered your question the issue of the
benefit that might arise for the council
just going back to the judgment in the
judicial review the benefit identified
by the judge was the benefit of the
regeneration aim
of the council for the area there is no
financial benefit involved
and mr levinson
i've just come back on the other two
points um one in terms of the defer and
delegate recommendation obviously
members are very familiar with the idea
of deferring delegating to officers it's
not that you're deferring the decision
to officers you are you would be
deciding to approve it this evening all
the officers are getting is a new signed
legal agreement so if it was that
members decided they wanted to defer to
bring back all that we would be bringing
back is a copy of that legal agreement
for you to look at and obviously what we
do is we get that checked by the
solicitors so in terms of the decision
that's the decision is being made this
evening there is no delegation of the
decision in that way you are deciding
whether to approve or or anything else
um just to pick up the point about
construction management plan that is
particularly noted in in the condition
with regards to site workers it's
condition 11.
and i absolutely agree with your point
council auburn it is a big issue with
regards to construction workers
especially contractors onto sites um it
is something that obviously be very
carefully looked at not only on this
site but any others but this one in
particular the reason we're putting on
the condition is very specific
we have just recently served a breach
condition notice on the developer
instant nicholas at wade because of
construction vehicles being parked and
not inside the site so this is something
that we're very very um familiar with um
and it is something that we would
therefore make sure is enforced thank
you
thank you um yeah obviously i i totally
understand
what mr livingston has said in relation
to different delegate
currently no i obviously know what that
what that means however
even though it is a legal illegal
agreement
um which would be looked at by our
solicitors and theirs as well
i do think in
regards to openness
concerning the judicial review that that
it should come back even if it's just
for that we read it and we nod and we
say that that's agreed but i do think
that should happen thank you
uh thank you councillor and council
bayford
thank you chair
as cancer auburn said it's
very difficult um to know how to
how to progress on this one um
i also have empathy with um the issues
with the school
and
the issues that are raised however
a lot more houses are going to be
developed on this site the houses that
we desperately need
we can't stand in the way of them we
need them
so how is the school going to adapt
to these other developments um this one
is relatively small and in my view
fairly well planned
it's relatively low rise
there's green there are green areas
i i
absolutely agree that the construction
management needs to be very very
carefully carried out
but
i can't really see that this particular
development
is
causing
issues above
those that are going to be
caused by the much much larger
developments which we have and which are
going to come forward and we'll we we
desperately need
so i've i'm afraid i
i really can't see any reason to object
to it
thank you how's the favorite cass
crandon
i confess i'm a little torn on very
similar lines um
it has been drawn to our attention that
there are other agreement areas in the
vicinity for house building and i know
we can't that's not a part of our
consideration
um but it has been mentioned and this
school is likely to find itself in the
middle
a whole bunch more stuff
what i actually wanted to ask of mr
livingstone
was
grounds for refusal
are disturbance to the uh the school and
the children in the school
um caused by construction
a ground for refusal
um
it's it's sort of partially covered in
the judicial review to an extent even
though that doesn't the judiciary
doesn't actually give a view on whether
or not there is an issue or not um
it acknowledges that obviously
construction and we talk about this
quite a lot construction has noise
impacts and obviously refusing an
application on the base of construction
noise when obviously that is just part
and parcel with development happening
anywhere um would be very very difficult
to sustain uh as a an impact to refuse
an application on um in this particular
instance um it has been raised as part
of the district that we needed to
further justify why we thought a
condition was appropriate to mitigate it
the concerns were
clearly that
the judge felt there was an assumption
made that the condition would just deal
with that would deal with the issue um
we obviously were working with
environmental health to make sure that
actually that condition would be
sufficient to make a difference
therefore on the basis of the additional
work that's been submitted and obviously
the advice that we've taken from our
environmental health department we feel
that the mitigation is sufficient and
therefore without the basis of any
evidence to to counter that and
therefore we don't have a demonstrable
harm that we could demonstrate when put
up against that mitigation um you know
officers do not consider that there is a
reason for refusal there for for this
particular ground
thank you chad
thank you ian councillor wright
thank you chair um like council over i
was on that same planning committee and
it was a problem then and kind of is a
problem again
um my mic
i'm actually between the devil and the
deep blue sea like everybody else but um
i'd be happier if the extra house the
extra houses that have been added onto
the application that would help to to
do something
[Music]
um
i i feel that my this is it
i i i'm planning we see this all the
time the developers put in an
application and then surprise surprise
halfway through they they they lop on
some more and i really don't think
that's right
um so my my problem is with the extra
houses thank you
thank you councillor wright um
councillor keane
thank you
i'm concerned about the quality of the
development on a number of fronts there
was one comment made in the report about
whether they met the standard size-wise
i mean i'm sure they must have done
because obviously that would have been
highlighted had it not been
but do they only just meet it it is
quite a dense development and also um i
was concerned about the comments from
the police about the safety issues of
the design of it and i haven't i don't
know if i've missed it but i haven't
seen anything that has revised those
plans to make it safer so can we hear
more about that please
go pay for this cat screen please
everest members just to make sure they
get things right
i think uh
emma sorry apologies for this we're just
trying to
find the um
the policy that has the national space
standards in it but in terms of the um
area of the units um
so the one bed units
are
40
yes the one bedroom the one bed units
are 45 square
meters the two bed units are 71 square
meters
um
some of the three bed also 71 going up
to 89 square meters
yes
so i'm just going to tag him and come in
there so
in terms of the the one bed units um
that unit which is i believe it says
it's a number of units which are 45
the the standard is 39 square meters so
six square meters more for two bedroom
units um it depends on the whether or
not it's a three person two bedroom unit
or four person two bedroom unit and the
the statistic differs so it's um 61
square meters and for the two bedroom
unit that's 71 square meters so again
we're 10 above
and with the other larger two bedroom
units being 89 square meters whereas the
the target is 70 square meters for the
four bed ones and similarly the three
bed ones are about a comparable amount
over so they're not
they're not wildly over
but they are sufficiently over so that
they're not just hitting the exact exact
mark on it
um
in terms of the the comment with regards
to uh the police um they've provided
some some detailed comments as you've
seen from the report one is to do with
um a relationship between the apartment
blocks and the recessed areas
it's not considered on
its own ground that that is an issue
that would be sufficient for us to
refuse the application in terms of
secure by design and designing out crime
uh by virtue of where those entrance
points are and the natural surveillance
that you get by virtue of the fact that
it's on the road those particular
those particular entrances in terms of
the
boundary treatments that is something
that's controlled i believe via
condition uh to ensure that they accord
with that there's a bullet point list in
the report which members can see about
the the heights that are required for
boundary treatments so it has been
considered uh in those details and
obviously it does also cover the issue
of of parking and natural surveillance
which is something that we are mindful
for when looking at the actual
conditions to do with again landscaping
and it is something that would be looked
at in that condition submission because
obviously as
you can see
you've got those two parking areas at
the front of the site
which are not directly surveilled by
certain dwellings other than the ones
that have been turned
perpendicular to the school and so what
we'd be looking at through a condition
submission is to just ensure that they
are well lit effectively so that there
is that surveillance
thank you
thank you ann uh councillor wing
thank you i mean i think if this was a
school if this was being built next to a
school a mainstream school where you
didn't have pupils with additional needs
then i would it would be i would be
voting in favor of this but uh i'm i'm
really aware of this site because i work
three days a week
out of the roll harbor academy and i'd
like clarification on the pl where the
playground is where the area that the
kids play in because i also think that
the map is wrong that the site of the
playground is wrong so i would like
clarification on that
uh i don't there's been nothing and i
taught for 26 years and i worked in a
school where there was a building
construction site happening next to the
school i taught in as a senior teacher
and i can tell you the impact of the
construction faith
on kids without additional needs was
quite horrific
so
an impact on on on young people with
additional needs both in the in terms of
the construction phase but also once
people move into that site and once
there's uh movement to and from that
site
i understand you there'll be one car
every three minutes but that's not the
way things work people go to work at a
set time
young people arrive and leave from from
a school at a set time and getting out
of that hane onto that hane roundabout
is very difficult even when there are
there is no traffic there so i do i
haven't heard anything that puts this
where the mitigations or the
consideration of the impact on on young
people has been put in the context of
students with additional needs
and these are students with additional
needs that that can't be fulfilled in a
mainstream setting so we're not talking
about mild additional needs we're
talking about complex additional needs
and these kids are very sensitive to a
whole whole range of a range of things
and i i think that there needs to be
greater consideration of that particular
group of of students if it was right
close to the royal harbour where there
isn't a significant number of students
with additional needs then then i i
think that appropriate assessment and
mitigations have been put in place but i
don't think enough has been looked at in
terms of this particular group of young
people and i think if if that isn't if
consider a strong consideration isn't
given
then there will be a significant impact
on those young people
thank you
do you wish to come back on that to talk
about the playground
ever
so
okay sorry i apologize for that
so this aerial view um you can see the
school in this location here
so
i've not personally been to the school
but i've walked around the outside of
the school and obviously looked at these
aerial views as well
i have taken it as that the
play space has been this area here which
is the contained space between the
buildings
not this area at the front here which is
already completely visible from the road
because there's railings and you can
look straight through into this space so
i have
obviously it's also in relation to the
proximity to the development side i was
assuming it is this area here because
this is the area that is closest to the
dwellings and is the area that is
not already overlooked from the road
thank you uh
count
counselor more pam
thank you chairman
uh
i'm not so much much asking questions as
wanting clarification
i mean
in my opinion
the best people
who who know how to deal with these
children
are their parents
and their teachers i have an autistic
grandson i know what it's like
and
we we have a duty of care to these
children
we can't let them go through something
like this which could do
awful damage to their health and their
mental health
and
if
this
this place this
site i believe is overdeveloped
and
so we need more housing
but
let's be honest how many local people
are going to live there
you can bet your life not many and how
many of the 5 000 people on the housing
waiting list
will live in them
again
not many
so
uh
and if all this is down to the local
plan
i think the local plan is not fit for
purpose
thank you
uh thank you casper
i'm coming back to emma for a moment
sorry i just i just wanted to clarify
whilst
i've said that i've assumed that it was
the century of the reason for this is as
you can see from this photo
the area to um on the right-hand side
which i think the parent has just
referred to
already has fencing you can see straight
through so it's not a private space
so if you're talking about the area in
front of the building this area you can
see has fence and you can see straight
through to that space so that's already
visible from people walking past
so
i read uh
it is rules of this
committee meeting
so this area here is
the one show sorry
this is the one where we just saw the
photo so this is the the fencing that
you can see through into this space
so this area here you can already see
into that space so i'm not aware of any
fencing or any boundary that completely
obscures um the view into this space so
that's why i was assumed that this area
here was the um the private space where
concerned is raised from the windows
take on points with the headmaster
um regarding the playground so
it's not normally done because there are
strict rules and regulations for this
committee to
here to including me as chair but
as this is so important to everybody
we want to get it right
thank you chair uh mr milton i just
wanted to confirm um obviously the area
that
we're particularly talking about in this
instance is the area that is between if
you can see the image up there between
the parking area for the commercial
units you've got the road and then you
have the area which is in front of the
sick form block obviously what we're
referring to is that area and when we're
talking about that isn't in our from our
view
um isn't the play area per se um
is it possible if you can confirm uh
using the image above if possible
where the areas are that are used by the
school for the particular play area
function
can you
climb over that's it
so the area in front of what was the
residential block did not used to get
used by pupils because it's a
residential block and that's what's
alluded to in the first round of
objections
when the when this was resubmitted
the use of the phoenix block has changed
it is no longer a residential block it's
a sixth form block so the area in front
by the road is used by our post 16 and
year 11s
during the school day
so i totally understand where the
confusion comes from because they're
right
behind the phoenix blocks was the is the
primary playground
and that's where the 45 meters comes
from but because of the change of use of
the phoenix block in the last two years
the air in front of the phoenix box
right next door to where those five
houses have been turned around to bring
them right up to the fence that is the
recreational area of our year 11's and
well actually it's year 10's at the
moment normally year 11's and our
post-16 and that's some of the
frustration for us is that there has
been a change of use so some of those
objections which were submitted nearly
two years ago
couldn't cause confusion
uh thank you i will bring mr limited
back
thanks for that clarification um so just
to pick up the point that um
uh emma fitments just raised um
obviously in terms of the the planning
impact of this type of view some
residential use next to a school such as
this obviously we have to take account
of the existing site circumstances and
obviously as identified by the
photographs and also by the the image
that you can see
that area itself is is
is not private
it is not private area in the sense of
the visibility that's there
so our view is that the relationship is
acceptable obviously that's that's
what's outlined in the report i am the
conscious of the comments that have been
made um by members and i appreciate i
haven't actually spoken to the chair
outside of this um this this meeting
about this or in this meeting about this
but i think some of the confusion could
be alleviated potentially if members
were as concerned as you are by visiting
the site
uh and i think that would then allow for
members to both understand the
relationship directly with the school
obviously it would need to be carefully
worked out how we would do it to
actually if it was possible to actually
go within the grounds of the school and
that was something that we could work
out
but if if the chair is is so minded and
the seconder who i cannot remember who
the second of the motion was councillor
bayford
um we're so minded that it may be worth
potentially putting forward um to
withdraw that motion and to put forward
for a site visit so that we can cover
these points and come back on some of
the points potentially next time that
members have raised this evening
thank you can i just confirm that that
photograph is at least four and a half
years old and the hedging along has
changed thank you
thank you um i've got councillor everett
and
counselor wing
down on my piece of paper but what was
going you've just heard from
ian was going through my mind as well
if you still wish to speak um
you i'm quite happy to but what has been
suggested
i would stop you speaking and we would
pull this
have a vote that you agree to pull in it
and have a site visit but we have to go
through as you know
a procedure
you still wish to speak yeah yeah
everything
i mean i think that would i think that
would be an excellent solution i think
it's quite clear we can't make a
decision when there's ambiguity about
how the school uses the site and that
will give officers an opportunity to
bring back
a proper response to the points that
have been made by the school thank you
so i think that's ideal thank you
councillor
i'd just like to confirm what the head
says it is several years old and that
the whole site is now screened with the
i believe screening and also
planting around there so it's quite it
is quite misleading unfortunately that
we haven't gotten up-to-date images of
of of the site because the school has
made every attempt to actually screen
the pupils from people in open view
thank you
cancer wing i just wanted to come back
on that image there is from two weeks
ago
um
i'm going to hold
i i thank you councillor alban i know i
have council crittenden and council
bayford here but i think i'm going to
stop
because the suggestion has been made
um first of all to do that
i'm going to
draw this item
propose that we withdraw this item from
this committee tonight i have to have
the second uh who has council of bayford
agree with me
and members agree
thank you i therefore propose a side
visit
um a second to please which is cancer
auburn
uh do members agree i think it does make
sense i know it doesn't matter how long
we take we've got to get this for
everybody's sake right
so um the site visit which i didn't
announce tonight um
will be friday
friday the 1st of april
i won't say any more than that members
but it's uh
so
i will call that um if you all agree
with the site visit friday the 1st of
april which will be 9 30.
so would you please
put your hands in the air if you are for
that
side of it
no okay
against
abstentions
that is carried so we will have a site
visit friday the 1st
of april and we will see for ourselves
the concerns
and
i thank you for your debate tonight and
thank you for your attendance uh
um we get there
thank you very much
thank you members and officers uh for
the report and everything there that now
concludes uh public speaking
um
i therefore would ask
our clerk to read the other applications
that are in front of you
if there are any of those applications
you wish to call
please
let me know
charles
thank you chair
thank you
we have 4a 20 windermere avenue rams get
we also have 4b
93 all saints avenue market
we
4c
147 westbrook avenue market
4d
saint peter's churchyard
hobview avenue broadstairs
four e
one two and three pack lodge monfill
avenue ramsgate
and lastly
4g
length to the north of fairland road and
the west of northwood road broadstairs
yes
thank you
thank you charles
for
g
thank you uh could i have a proposal to
move that
those applications that have not been
reserved be determined in accordance
with the office of recommendations
uh could i have a second please
counselor auburn do members agree
thank you
right a bit of shuffling to pay for work
here now members for a moment please
sorry chair
um all saints having um i'm not sure if
we should have we should discuss that
one because it he it is council abroad
wait
uh we don't
no
longer unless it's
we don't have to
a member so
okay um
[Music]
right
item for a
which um
some shopping paperwork around now
excuse me
yep 20
windermere avenue and then uh
it is down for
recommendation is for approval and it's
mr livingston i presume
thank you chair um so the application is
for the direction of a single story rear
extension together with a dormer window
and some roof lights so the site is
identified with this google image here
with the red dot so it's a bungalow in
the nethercore estate
um
so this is the front uh photo the front
of the property
you can see the side
side rear garage here so it's slightly a
regular plot because it's sort of
diagonal to the back uh where the
railway line is and you can see the
level difference there with the property
in the middle and the level difference
the neighbor on the right hand side
this is the rear elevation so now we're
looking at the gap between the garage on
the left and the rear of the dwelling on
the right so you can see that there is
an existing
rear extension on the back of that
property
you've got
the rear extension as you can see and
you can see the neighboring property
also has a conservatory at the back and
you can see the boundary treatment on
the left hand side there
so this is just a longer distance view
of the property itself
so we've got the existing floor plans
and then the proposed so as mentioned
you've got a side and rear extension so
the rear extension single storey is
extending out by 1.4 meters from the
existing to create an overall depth of
that rear single story element
of 3.9 you've then also got a side
element which sort of attaches then to
that garage that we looked at and then
you've got a the first floor layout is
on the right hand side there so what
you've got is a dorm window
at the rear you've got an ensuite which
is served by the roof lights at the
front
worth noting this juliet balcony here so
this has actually been moved as part of
the proposal originally that julia
balcony was on the left-hand side closer
to the neighbour that's raised concerns
so it's been shifted over
so just look at the elevations
particularly
you've got the existing elevations that
we looked at in the photos
and then the proposed elevation so what
you've got there again is that
the extension that you can see out from
uh the rear uh which is obviously
includes that side element and then you
have the dorm window itself being put
into that roof slope so you can see
where the dorm window is on the bottom
right hand side there
so in terms of
the relationship with
neighboring properties
in terms of the increase in depth by
1.4 meters
it's not considered that results in a
sense of enclosure to the neighbor
that's directly adjacent you can see the
relationship at the moment with um the
fact that you're effectively bringing
that closer to the you know closer to
the where the photo has been taken from
but just by the 1.4 so the height isn't
isn't greatly above the existing and it
above the existing boundary fence to
impact on the conservatory that's next
door in terms of the dorm window that
has obviously been proposed we've
changed it to try and alleviate some of
the impact on the neighboring property
but actually the dorm window
fundamentally is looking down the garden
it's not looking directly into the
neighboring property's garden dorm
windows as we know from discussing this
are normally permitted development in
the rear roof slope is simply the size
of it which is the issue here in terms
of the the scale of the development
and so overlooking down the garden and
not directly into the side is the key
element the balcony itself is not one
that you step out on it's juliet balcony
so you can't actually look side to side
to look into those those areas those
private immunity spaces
and therefore it is considered that the
development is acceptable and therefore
it's recommended for approval thank you
chair
thank you very much and i moved the
office's recommendation for who is
adopted could i have a second to please
councillor wayford members
council auburn
yeah thank you cheer um
the reason i asked uh for us to discuss
this chair was that
initially at the start of when the
application was submitted i was
contacted by the next door neighbor
it's not my award
however as
she was an elderly lady and she'd been
given my name by another resident
i decided that it was the
best part of valor to go and to go and
visit the lady
and her concerns on the original
application
was the juliet balcony which was which
was located on looking at this on the
right hand side
and having been in a rear garden and
looked at what the development was
likely to be i was also concerned about
the i would be overlooking with the use
of the juliet balcony because it would
be right into her garden and also
um
the impact of the dormer window uh
itself
was worrying for her however um with the
with the change of the juliet balcony to
the other side of the
um
dormer window i do consider it to be
acceptable chair so thank you
thank you councillor alban to any other
members wish to comment
okay thank you members so i'll put this
to the vote uh for approval
uh those in favor
against
abstentions
that is carried unanimous
thank you very much members
right
again now moving on
[Music]
to the one that's been called which is
the land of fair lawn road and
the west of northwood road import stairs
uh we're doing well here emma i think
it's down to you again isn't it
i asked the officer to give the report
please
foreign
apologies for that i did have it but it
decided to jump back to the beginning of
the presentation so
here we are this is the application site
outlining red here so this is furlong
road
um
below the application site you can see
northwood road off on the right hand
side
and this is the aerial view of the site
so
the site is
allocated for housing within the thanic
local plan it forms part of a large
allocation
so the application site is this area
here
but in terms of the allocation within
the local plan this is the allocation in
the local plan so in the local plan
there's a notional 45
units that the site as a whole is
advocated for and this is just the small
part at the end of fernando road that
we're considering tonight
um in terms of other considerations the
rest of this site is also
allocated for housing just so you're
aware because this comes into play later
on when considering the pedestrian link
and then this is the um
closer view of the application site so
on this area again this is this is
probably a few years old as well now
because we just um
just use whatever is on google as the
aerial view of the site and you can see
that there are some trees located in
this area here and i think this was one
of the concerns that's been raised with
lots of trees
none of these trees are protected by a
tpo so you'll see in the face of the
minute that these trees in this location
here are no longer on the site
and then again you can see the the view
here so you can see fairlawn road you
can see that it's um pairs of
semi-detached two-story
pitch roof houses and the application
site is this area at the end of the
cul-de-sac
so this is now in fairlawn road looking
towards the application sites the
application site is at the head of the
cul-de-sac here
and now this is the actual application
site itself so it's overgrown this is
looking towards the western boundary so
there are some trees um close to the
western boundary these are being
retained um i think some of these
actually fall just outside the
application boundary but actually have a
spread that overhang
the site
this is then looking towards the
northern boundary so you can see that
the the owner has started to put up a
boundary
between the application site before you
which is the air in front of the fencing
and the area behind
which is
part of a pending application that we
currently have in
so this again a view towards the site
looking towards the north so that's the
far
boundary in the distance of the
overallocation but the actual site
boundary of this site is again in this
location here and then this is looking
over to the eastern boundary so the east
boundary follows that fence line
and this building and the building on
the left here are part of the um site to
the north so forming part of the the
other allocation
so this is back in fairlawn road
um looking towards the nearest
neighbouring property so this is number
11 fair long road and there's a
substation between number 11 and the
application sites you can see the the
access point there so there's a slightly
wider gap between this property and the
application site
and this is number 12 fernan road
and you can see that they've extended
with a two-story extension which goes
right up to the boundary with the
application site
this is then looking back towards the
other end of fairlawn so again you can
see the the building form within the
road quite consistent with the two-story
semi-detached design within the
cul-de-sac
and then this is the view from northwood
road looking towards the existing access
into the site
so this is the existing access into the
neighboring site to the north which
forms parts of the a separate
application
but this is the currently the only way
in which the application site can be
accessed so the proposal through the
application is to access the site from
fairlawn road
so here you just can see the um the
allocation within the local plan so
this slightly darker brown line here is
the outline of the
45 unit allocation so that's
the overall larger site and then this
application site is just this area down
here
so the proposal is for six dwellings
four of them are four bed
um
and you can see there's four
four pairs of or two pairs of semi-touch
properties and two detached dwellings
each of the properties have two parking
spaces to the front
in terms of the layout you can see that
it follows the pattern of development
within fairlawn road
so and the property is all front the
main
extended access road to the end of the
site
with the two detached weddings set back
from from the frontage and then you can
see that there's a
continuation of the road that extends
off to the east and this provides a
small parking court area this contains
two parking spaces that serve um the
detached way into the beach got one
parking space to the front and then a
parking space each within the parking
call and then there's two visitor
parking spaces as well within that
parking call area
um you can see the they've each got um
quite deep gardens again consistent with
the um size of plots that you can see
within furlong road
so in terms of the general pattern of
development it does it is considered to
be in keeping with um the development
within fairlawn road
so this is a closer view of it so of the
site plan
and then you can see there's a
pedestrian access that runs through the
properties to the parking court
and just you see here this area
highlighted blue this is the area that
we're looking at as a potential
pedestrian connection to the
neighbouring site so some concerns were
raised by residents regarding this
becoming a through route that would
potentially link onto the
housing development um that's being
proposed for the northern site that's
not what is currently being considered
this is um currently just an extension
of the cul-de-sac
and then vehicular access would would
stop at this point here and just be able
to get access to this parking court area
but we are looking at whether we can
achieve a pedestrian connection that
would go into the neighbouring site and
then beyond that would continue again
onto the millennium way allowing for
improved pedestrian connectivity to the
town centre which will come through next
to tesco
so in terms of the design this is the
the design of the properties so there's
reference has been made to the existing
properties in the road so the um
the general height and form is similar
so the roof pitches are slightly
different
and the windows designs are slightly
different but the similar materials have
been used so they're looking to match
the the brick material to those
properties um in the road they're also
looking to use some timber cladding
which again is similar to um some
cladding detailing which is with in the
existing properties between the doors
and first floor windows
and
roof materials again are looking to
match so in that in that way would be in
keeping with the existing properties but
they are looking to slightly modernize
the dwellings with slightly different
proportion windows slightly longer
windows and there would also be um a a
small single story flat roof
projection on the front of the buildings
and you can see that there's a slightly
different proportion of the ground floor
windows again though that's trying to
mimic the proportion of the windows
within the existing properties at ground
floor level
on the rear
of the so many attached properties uh
dormer window so these are the four bed
units with the dormer window at first
floor at second floor level
this is the side view of the semi
detached properties so again you can see
the door window and you can see the
small projection at the front and the
rear
and then this floor plan of the
properties so you can see the three
bedrooms at first floor level and then
another bedroom at roof level
and then this is the detached unit so
these are three bed units um
you can see these the front and rear
elevations again similar in design to
the the um three bed units uh four bed
units sorry and then again is the side
view of those properties
and again the floor plans showing the
three bed units
and this is the other detached unit
so these are some street elevations you
can see so this
top these are looking towards the
northern boundary from fair lawn so as
if you were in fairlawn looking towards
the northern boundary which would um
have some new boundary treatment erected
along it these are the semi-detached
properties closest to you and then
further back you can see the setback
detached units
and then this is a view as if looking
from the northern boundary back into
fair lawn so again you can see the
detached units so there's attaching to a
slightly higher ground level because the
ground is changing and increasing in
height
and so the difference between the ridge
height of the detached units and the
existing ridge height of the neighboring
properties in fernand road is 1.3 meters
um the obviously the semi detached units
are in between that measurement so it's
just slightly rising and high as you
reach the end of the cul-de-sac
and then this is the street elevation
you can see in terms of the impact on
the neighbours
so on the top one you can see the
relationship with number 11 failing rose
you can see that that's the substation
in between the units there's a distance
of 4.5 meters
between these properties and in terms of
the rear elevation it's it's it is
similar in similarly in line to the
re-elevation of of the existing
neighboring property so the impact on
these properties are considered to be
acceptable
the bottom one you can see the impact on
number 12. so they've got the two-story
side extension so there's a slightly
smaller gap between the properties
and
this plot here is actually extending
slightly further out so i'll just show
you that relationship
so this is the relationship with number
12. so you can see that number six plot
six is a deeper
property um it's 3.8 meters beyond the
rear elevation of number 12 but you can
see that the um architect has placed the
45 degree line from the nearest window
on the plan and it just falls outside of
that area so we would actually be
looking as part of any approval to
restrict any future development of this
plot so it can't extend any further into
the garden which would then subsequently
have an impact on number 12.
in terms of overlooking there's no side
windows there's no loss of privacy for
the properties and so overall the impact
on these properties given the distance
or or the limit or the depth and the
fact it doesn't fall within the 45
degree line and the fact there's no side
windows the impacts on these properties
in terms of living conditions is
considered to be
acceptable in terms of the actual
future units the um they meet the space
standards they each have um gardens and
they have refuge storage to the front of
the site
so
this was an issue that came up to do
with um to do the highway so obviously
you can see the highway plan is to
extend the cul-de-sac but it's quite and
it does provide a turning head which
actually is a benefit for the road
because currently the road has no
turning head at the end so any vehicles
that drive along here would just
have to either do quite a big
three-point turn or reverse back so this
is actually a benefit for the road to
have a turning head for smaller vehicles
but it isn't a turning head for
a refuse truck and it isn't a turning
head for a fire engine because they're
much larger and the turning head would
need to be significantly larger as well
so concerns were originally raised in
terms of whether that was an issue or
not and we have some advice from the
waste recycling department they
currently
reverse down the road and said they
would be happy on this occasion to
reverse the extra distance in order to
collect the refuge from these additional
six units
and highways advisor if if that's the
case they have no concerns with the
turning and it would be a similar case
for um for any uh fire truck that again
the fire truck as existing would be
reversing down the road it would just be
the same situation they'd have to
reverse slightly further obviously
ambulances and police cars and things
like that would be out of turn because
they're slightly smaller
so that um highways have said they have
no no concerns of the proposal they're
happy with the parking provision being
provided
um and they would support the provision
of the the pedestrian link if that can
be achieved
in terms of landscaping and biodiversity
obviously as mentioned there's there's
been concern with the
loss of the trees on the site but we're
not able to protect those that they
aren't protected so the fact that these
are being removed is
we can't do anything about that now but
we can look at whether we can try and
improve biodiversity through this scheme
so kcc biodiversity did raise some
concerns with the lack of
enhancements for ecology being shown on
the site so we have sort of mended plans
to try and um improve this so if i just
sort of go through to the soft
landscaping plan so this is a soft
landscaping plan as amended it's showing
um native hedge planting around quite a
lot of the boundaries so we've got along
the northern boundary here further along
south and around these boundaries here
you can see that they're now proposing
new tree planting so all of the number
sevens on the circles these are all new
tree planting within the site so
there'll be additional 10 trees planted
within the site
um and also the plan now shows um bat
and
bat boxes and b boxes or b
holes within the building which is what
was encouraged by um casey biodiversity
so they are also indicated on this plan
and therefore would be
provided
so
on balance whilst there is some loss of
trees
there's quite large gardens there's
going to be new planting and that's all
controlled through the landscaping
condition
the frontages have also been slightly
mended because again these were fully
hard surface so we've attempted to try
and achieve some soft landscaping to the
front of these where we can in order to
try and soften
the development
so
[Music]
in terms of
the legal agreement there's a
contribution required towards the spa
which has been agreed to the
applications currently for defer and
delegate for us to receive that legal
agreement we have actually received the
signed copy of that legal agreement so
we are able to secure that contribution
so
the application is recommended for
refuse uh i refuse on approval even
sorry
all right
on the basis that it is allocated
housing site it's a sustainable site
within close proximity of the town
centre the design um is considered to be
in keeping with the pattern development
and the character of the area there's no
significant highway or living condition
issues and therefore it is recommended
for a defer and delegate for approval
on the basis that we need the legal
agreement which we have but is still
subject to that coming
thank you emma
and i know it's getting late
[Laughter]
thank you
thank you members i move the officers
recommendation is adopted could i have a
second to please
casa bayford uh he has a right take a
pic
right
members it's over to you
anybody wish to see my
cousin
thank you yeah and thank you for giving
that presentation
um
yeah though
i've been i'm the local wall councillor
just fairlawn road rather similar to the
other one fellow mode isn't in my ward
but the
the better land that it's actually been
building built on
is and a number of the local residents
have contacted me
with a number of concerns
about this and
as much the associated application which
obviously we're
considering this in isolation but it's
going to be very difficult to consider
it in isolation because there are
two that are delivering
uh 50 houses
in total on there um i think like you
said it was allocated in the plan for
45.
um and there's quite a lot of crossover
between the two which
we can't totally ignore
um
a couple of points i wanted to raise
that were raised with me
you mentioned about kcc highways
and the difficulty basically extending
fairlawn road and the fire the um any
fire trucks and certainly the waste
recycling will have to reverse that
little bit further
i know you said the wasted tdc waste
recycling
have accepted that well i did read their
their submission
and i don't think they were particularly
happy about it but whether they had a
lot of choice i don't know but it's
certainly going to add
we saw on the picture all the cars
parked either side
it's going to add to that so it's going
to make it a lot more difficult for
for collections
one thing that what hasn't been
mentioned
but is mentioned in the report
is archaeology
and i didn't know this before but
actually there's quite a
uh a rich
archaeological history on that site a
number of different things were
mentioned and there is a condition
on notice that
a full archaeological survey has to be
completed
before
any work starts on it
and this is where
the link to the other application comes
in
really because
to do a full application survey on the
site you need to use the whole you need
to do it on the whole site
you can't
just take this little snapshot of the
bottom of the site and do it there
totally ignore and then go on with the
building when
the other site which may or may not be
developed later hasn't been surveyed um
so that's just something we have to
consider it needs to all to be done
in one
one point that's one of the reasons why
i would have rather had both the
applications if possible
to to come before us at the same time
because that would also help us
to get a better understanding of the
the
um potential overcrowding on this
on this whole site which is allocated
for 45 but actually delivering quite a
few more
houses
as we mentioned again with the highways
there
there is a condition that access to the
site for construction can't be up
fairlawn fairlawn road it has to be
from northwood road
by there by the
uh entrance and exit these shoulders
as i understand it that is part of
and the ownership of the other part of
this site
i mean obviously that needs confirming
but
the act that
as i understand it both the this site is
a portion to two different owners so
there's one with the other application
44 and this one for six
so again
this is where the two applications come
in i don't
i don't understand how this development
can be started
sorry that's my medication alone
i can wait though
um
no no no so i don't i don't understand
how
develop our development on this one
small site at the end can actually
progress
without the other application being
being considered at the same time and
access being granted
to the the different developer to come
and develop on this on this site
um
the other thing i want to uh to mention
biodiversity
yeah it is very disappointing actually
that
this site a number of years ago had a
lot more trees on it and they have
as you say they're not covered by a tpo
so
you know the the owner of the site is
quite within their rights legally if not
morally to cut all the trees as many
trees as they like down
so it's very difficult to know when
measuring
um net biodiversity gain or loss
starts because if we take it from
before the trees were gonna were cut
down there's not going to be any chance
of any sort of net biodiversity gain on
this site
but by the developer cutting all the
tree or the majority of the trees down
they're in with the shell of getting
some net biodiversity gain on the site
and i did i did notice
reading the
submission from
kcc biodiversity that they did ask they
were sort of aware that i think you
mentioned this
but um they want to see an ongoing
programme
of clear ecological enhancements for
breeding birds and bats including for
yeah cooling provision for bat boxes and
native planting
so really we're going to be
relying on the people who buy these
houses
to
contribute to net biodiversity gain now
it's all very well putting a few trees
on the
on the plan
to say they're going to be planted there
but unless we're
putting
like individual tpos or any other sort
of constraints on people who buy those
houses they're only going to last as
long as what the people who buy the
houses want them to last
um so
i think this application
without being considered in the hole
with the other one falls down on on the
net biodiversity
um gain
um
i think
i'll leave it at that for now and
hopefully some other people will have be
able to contribute to the debate
thank you
thank you thank you you worry me there
for a moment before i bring in cancer
everett uh emma
um i just wanted to come back on a few
of those points so in terms of the um
construction access this condition has
been agreed with the applicant so
yeah the two there are two separate
sites but they currently are accessed
from that norfolk road access
um
the condition was put on because of the
concerns raised by residents regarding
construction vehicle traffic and it was
seemed it seemed reasonable to require
that the construction vehicle should
come from norfolk road being that is the
existing access point to the site and
will result in the least disruption for
the residents
and i think it's likely then that they
probably that if a separate developer to
the other side
deals with this site obviously they have
to get the agreement with that developer
to be able to achieve it if they can't
they'll have to come back in with a
separate application um to vary that
condition which we will again look at
um in terms of what you'll mention in
terms of the two sides i agree it would
it would have been useful if maybe the
two sites could have come forward at the
same time but unfortunately we're still
negotiating on the other application
um looking at the the overall layout
number of units on that application
and we've had a lot of concerns on that
one raised by residents again that's
that's currently being negotiated they
are quite separate sites this site is
seen in the context of fairlawn road the
other site will be separate its own
development that's going to be accessed
off northwood road
in terms of the conditions each site has
to comply with its own conditions so an
archaeology condition for this site
would have to be comply for for this
site they would look at whether they
need to do any
um
of digs on the site to look for any
archaeology and all they would be
required to do is this area they
wouldn't be expected to do beyond that
so it's difficult to
to to suggest that we could look at the
site as a whole obviously if if casey
archaeology asked for the same condition
on the neighboring site which they are
likely to do then there will be the
requirement to deal with that but issues
could be done separately
um
in terms of the biodiversity point
yes it's a shame that the trees were
lost um i mean we've attempted through
amendments to get as much
improvement with the landscaping through
this development um
with the native planting with the burden
bee boxes with the new tree planting
which wasn't originally proposed as part
of this scheme
we've attempted to do what we can with a
site that is allocated for housing and
basically have to accept that there is
going to be housing on it what can we do
though to try and get as much
biodiversity benefits as possible and
it's considered that this reaches that
appropriate balance given the fact that
the previous trees weren't weren't
protected or in a conservation area so
thank you
uh thank you
council over it
yes thank you chad i don't see anything
wrong with the application personally
but i'm just curious about this rather
strange parking call i mean it appears
to me to be some sort of a contrivance
to escape the fact that they can't get
two vehicles on the on the front of the
two detached properties and accommodate
the turning head so it's rather a
strange thing now um emma referred to
the gardens being large so perhaps the
garden of the property at the top right
is large even though it looks quite
truncated on there perhaps you could
tell me how big that garden is please
can you do that
yes
uh the
um hang on i did write this down sorry
uh here it is 7.5 meters depth is the
smallest garden
which would be that top right hand plot
um and then the other properties have
gardens of 23 and a half meters
deep
so yeah i think that parking court was
being created obviously they needed some
visitor parking spaces and you're right
they couldn't actually achieve
um
the parking spaces at the front of the
properties if you were going to get the
turning head in which as i've mentioned
the turning head is beneficial for the
road so
if they end up just trying to put some
parking space into the front of the
properties and not achieving the turning
head
i just think that turn ahead is
beneficial so that's why we've ended up
with the two parking spaces in the
parking call which whilst not completely
easily located to the properties there's
the footpath obviously runs down to them
and it would be like the second car
that's used within the property and they
do have that one parking space at the
front for the main user
can i just say chair i mean it does seem
21 foot i think seven and a half meters
roughly what we're talking about it's
quite shallow garden for a property that
big
i'm not saying that we should turn it
down on those grounds it just seems to
me a bit undesirable
thank you councilor cancer king
thank you i just wanted to clarify
something because i i think council of
ghana raised a really interesting point
about biodiversity gain and
when do we
start from because surely this leads to
people being able to chop down all the
trees in that in advance and then just
plant one and it's again
we may have an answer for you here
council clean
so i was going to come in earlier but i
i i can speak to this um the
um so the changes are occurring this
year to be enacted next year in the town
of country planning act to bring the
environment act um into sort of a
statutory responsibility for planning
applications
will include the provision for small
sites like this
to have to submit a certain amount of
information with their planning
application which will include the use
of a metric by that's been created by
defra which will work out and calculate
on biodiversity units whether or not
there is net gain or not now the key bit
you raise is well someone could just cut
down everything on the site
and then they you know put it in and say
oh we planted one tree therefore it's
again
that provision is effectively going to
be
the the starting point is going to be on
the base of the date when the
environment act came into force which
was last year last year beginning this
year
that date which is now already gone so
basically what would happen is if
someone then cut stuff down
we would refer and casey biodiversity
would refer to the aerial photographs
that we've got the site when they were
dated the street view images and say
well there are trees here that clearly
that data that you've provided us is
insufficient
um
so there is going to be provision within
the changes in the town of country
planning act to look at that point at
the moment there is still provision
within the national planning policy
framework to look at um biodiversity net
gain in uh paragraph 170
174
but
with this scheme for example we would
always look to try and get enhancements
above where we are now and that starting
point but in the future when looking at
biodiversity net gain in a much more
detailed fashion which is what will be
happening when the act changes for the
planning act
we will have a lot more data and we will
be able to be able to sort of
avoid developers just raising a site and
then putting it in basically
thank you council bathroom
thank you chair um just to say that
personally i
can't see anything wrong with this site
i think that
um
planned housing is never going to fit
exactly into the spot we want to put it
compromises have to be made i think many
of the concerns have been hypothetical
from what we see tonight i can't see any
reason to refuse this development thank
you
thank you
thank you members i can't see
council ghana
thank you i just thought i'd come back
because i just wanted to make a couple
of points
or to
at least
it sounds like
um this is likely to be approved so
i would like to start to make a couple i
went up there earlier today and
which is where i saw there quite a lot
of trees being cut down
quite a few haven't and there is still
quite a a large amount of hedges
there is a lot of life up there at the
moment there's a lot of birds
flying about
starting to build their nests
so i know there's a condition on there
about
um that you know not being able to
cut down trees or hedges during the bird
nesting season so we are in the bird
nesting season so they wouldn't be able
to start work on this
until the end of the bird nesting season
which is um
see next october so
i would hope that we keep an eye on
someone will keep an eye on them i
certainly will and if if i let anybody
know that work has started there
um hopefully action will be taken
thank you uh thank you for that uh
council ghana okay members i'm going to
put this to the vote uh
those in favor for defer and delegate
please show hands
those against
abstentions
that is carried thank you members
we haven't finished yet
agenda item five and i've changed my
classes
which is the former westernville garage
most of us know it as or knew it as
jenna's on the canterbury road
margate
um
you never guess who the planning officer
is who is going to give out the report
on this
i wonder who
thank you emma
okay so um this is brought back
before members um due to the length of
time has passed since the legal
agreement since the previous um case was
brought before members so
it was brought before members
in
february 2020 with a resident and a
resolution to grant was made subject to
the submission of a signed legal
agreement within six months of the
committee date
the signed legal agreement has just been
submitted so it's now
two years since that committee meeting
um in that time we've had the new local
plan adopted so this has just been
brought back before members
just to put it back before you um look
at an update in relation to the new
local plan
um and um
due to the fact that the legal
agreement's taken so long to come in so
just to remind members of this
application um so it's this this site
area
here so we've got westbrook gardens on
the left
and canterbury road
um on the right hand side here
and this is an aerial view of the site
so this is the tesco's express in
westbrook um and you can see this is the
the site here
and then another view of the site you
can see it's overgrown area i think
formally um it was a garage site um you
can see the outline of of the original
building but there's now nothing no
presence of any buildings on the site
and we previously considered this
um through the um the reason it actually
came to members originally was because
it was classed as being non-produced
event land
and policy h1 that we had at the time
said that it was non-profit land it was
um had to be brought before members as a
departure to the policy so this is now
no longer the case the policy h01
allows for development
in the urban confines it doesn't require
it to be non-proof to develop land no
appreciate land doesn't require to be
prevented about land it can be nonprofit
land and still comply with the policy as
long as it's within the urban confines
so it's now no longer a departure to the
plan
so and this is just the application site
here you can see it's again very
overgrown
and this is a view again from canterbury
road looking towards the site
and you can see again test goes on the
right hand side here
and then you can just see the sites on
the left here
and this is again looking with the
application site in the distance here
and then this is now taken from um next
to tesco so the application site is on
the left just so you can see um the
nearest neighboring property to the site
and then again just taken from the other
side of the road looking towards it and
again you can see so with this you could
just see the scale of the development
around there is mainly three stories um
around there and again it's now taken
from um
the
side road i forgot the name of it
restaurant garden sorry yeah westbrook
gardens with the application site
and and just throwing this one in this
is just basically the sea bathing
development um you can see that how this
has progressed this would have been
since the previous application was in so
this is just in westbrook gardens the
other end of westbrook gardens with the
application site on the right hand side
so the proposal that came before members
before it was an application for a part
three story part four story part five
story building comprising fifteen
two bed flats and three one bed flats
with basement parking
so just to remind you this is the um
ground floor plan showing the unit so
there was some
gardens to the front we have some
hedging
and then this is the access into the
basement parking on the left-hand side
here from westbrook gardens
and then a ground floor and then this is
the upper floor so they've got balconies
on the front wrapping around
and then this is the top floor so the
top floor was set in from both sides in
order to reduce the the overall
dominance of the building and better
relate to the neighbors
this is the basement parking area which
enabled
16 parking spaces
and then these were the elevations of
the scheme so you can see that there
were there's quite a few amendments when
this application was in trying to make
sure that it tied in with the
neighboring properties and sat well
within the street
um and the top floor as i mentioned was
originally larger we've reduced that in
scale and you can see the the variation
materials and and um balconies are on
that elevation so that's how the
elevation sits within canterbury road in
relation to tesco's but in terms of the
the height the main height of it is
similar to buildings around there
obviously it's quite a prominent corner
location on a main road so it can take a
larger building
and then this was a view from westbrook
gardens
so this view was this uh designed
slightly different where we tried to
reflect the design of the existing
properties within westbrook gardens you
can see the similar fenestration
and balcony details at the similar
levels
and then this was the side view and the
rear view
and this was the
impression of what the scheme would look
like so in terms of relating it to the
new plan as mentioned the
one of the main issues is the fact that
it's no longer a departure to the plan
because it now complies with policy sbo1
and policy h01
in terms of the
impact on the currency of the area
policy d1 has been replaced with qual
policy qd01 but it basically looks at
the same thing is it in keeping with the
character of the area
um does it enhance this you know the
area is is the scale and design
acceptable so this was previously
considered to be acceptable so we don't
consider that there's anything that's
changed now that would um weren't us
looking at
any a different conclusion to this
in terms of the living conditions we now
have the nationally described space
standards and policy that's come in so
that wasn't considered when the original
application was in so we've looked at
all the flat sizes just to check it
complies and they do
so um
the unit schedule's been submitted with
it we can see that it does meet the
minimum which is the um
for for one bed two person unit it was
50 and for the two bed two
four person unit it's 70 so they are
achieving those
then in terms of the transport the
parking um is still obviously a basement
level there's no change in the parking
division we still look at the interim
guidance note 3 for parking provision so
that hasn't changed so the impact on
highway is fine
and in terms of the affordable housing
so this site
is one where either they can develop
this site and provide 30
or it's actually attached to um a site
that's in
cliftonville on the seafront and this
was actually when that scheme was
approved this was actually the
affordable housing contribution for that
site so if that site goes ahead this
needs to be fully affordable housing if
this site goes ahead on its own
it needs 30 so the legal agreement
that's why it's taken so long to get
this legal agreement sorted because it
has to have these two options within it
either the 30 or fully providing it and
linking back to the legal agreement of
the um the other scheme in cliftonville
um so in terms of the unit size is a mix
and that's been slightly updated
recently with the new smart but it's
it's again it's similar to
what was previously proposed
and um really there's no all the other
policies there's no other issue so
ecology drains contamination archaeology
nothing really needs updating with those
because these will previously considered
fine
and no changes to the financial compute
contributions they're now within this
legal agreement they've signed it the
council has signed and sealed it
and therefore we are now happy to
approve the application it complies with
the location with the
development plan and we have the legal
agreement so it's recommended for
approval thank you
uh thank you emma um i recommend the
officer's recommendation have a second
please
counts robin are there any members wish
to speak
counselor cringing
i would just like a comment really i i'm
i think the building doesn't really look
like it's terribly in keeping with the
area but apart from that i really don't
have any objections i think it is at
least a
an improvement on the land as it is at
the moment
if i may come in which is very unusual
for me to comment this is in
westbrook ward as you might gather
the site itself has been derelict for a
long long time as you've seen by the
pictures
obviously
we all know we get complaints and
everything else this is one of them
um
the view here
and obviously you've seen other
photographs of the views of this
proposed property
okay
if you go down westbrook gardens to the
left of this photograph
yes they're all some victorian
and i used to live down there um not in
victorian times before anyone says
anything
but as you go around onto the
canterbury road you have the tesco
building which
is
fairly modern
few older shops but then you go down to
another development where the old duck
and duck pub used to be
that again is a more of a modern so
totally understand what you're saying i
hope you don't mind me just
coming in on that but um
it would be good to see
thank you
any other members
thank you very much um i'm going to put
that to the vote then those in favor
please show
anybody against
no extensions that is carried
thank you members a special thank you to
emma tonight for doing the marathon run
and
charles
thank you charles who's sitting quietly
at the end andy and and
and yourselves
don't forget site visit on the 1st of
april
take care
and good night thank you
you